[Música]
Y a propósito del Día Mundial sin tabaco
y de las alternativas que se plantean
con los vapeadores pero que siguen
siendo tóxicos nos conectamos en Berna
Suiza donde está luquia Luciano rubia Él
es director de la asociación Suiza para
la prevención del tabaquismo que es la
principal organización del país por la
lucha por el control y la prevención
bienvenido aquí a France 24 y Comencemos
a por hablar Cuál es la diferencia entre
un cigarrillo de vapeador y un
cigarrillo electrónico
Buenos días
[Música]
electrónicos como como esto que son
único no sé es esto puede ser mejor
contienen nicotina pero no contienen
tabaco otros dispositivos como como de
calentador de trabajo con trabajo esa es
una diferencia fundamental
claro queríamos preguntarle en ese
sentido no muchos creen que al tener
otras opciones de tabaco o al no perdón
de no consumir tabaco con los vapeadores
o al no tener que encenderlos no con un
encendedor que eso es más saludable Es
realmente Así es decir Qué efectos
nocivos pueden tener
no es bastante complicado
como una herramienta para ayudarla a las
personas a dejar de fumar luego son
temas complicado y hay muchas
investigaciones en curso En este acto
existen algunos estudios que sugieren
que los cigarrillos electrónicos pueden
ayudar a algunos formatos a dejar de
fumar o reducir su consumo de trabajo
sin embargo es importante recordar
algunas cosas el uso de cigarrillos
electrónicos europea no está libre de
riesgos los cigarrillos electrónicos aún
contienen típicamente nicotina que es
Adictiva es una droga también pueden
contener otras sustancias
potencialmente dañinas la efectividad
puede variar la ayuda de dejar de fumar
mientras que alguna persona puede tener
éxito en dejar de fumar al cambiar a los
electrónicos otras pueden obtenerlo y
los efectos a largo plazo de los
cigarrillos electrónicos no se conocen
completamente como producto
relativamente nuevo los impactos a largo
plazo en la salud todavía se están
estudiando y también un problema yo es
el uso Dual es una preocupación alguna
persona puede terminar juzgando tanto
cigarrillos electrónicos electrónicos
como cigarrillos tradicionales lo que
puede limitar cualquier beneficio
potencial es importante destacar también
que muchos países desde que los
cigarrillos electrónicos están en el
mercado no hemos visto un descenso de la
prevalencia del tabaco
y yo le quiero preguntar si bien usted
nos está explicando que todavía no se
conocen Cuáles son las consecuencias a
largo plazo que se conoce hasta ahora de
cuáles son los efectos nocivos que
pueden tener los vapeadores y los
cigarrillos electrónicos sobre todo
porque ya hay países que se han movido a
prohibirlos como es el caso de México y
Argentina
exactamente y hay países como Inglaterra
que están como viendo los cigarrillos
electrónicos Pues los riesgos para la
salud asociada con el papel Todavía
están bajo investigaciones existe un
mito Comparado por la industria
Tabacalera según el cual los cigarrillos
electrónicos son 905% menos peligrosos
que los cigarrillos es una mentira sin
base científica alguna los cigarrillos
electrónicos contienen potencialmente
menos sustancias tóxicas Esta es una
edad pero nadie puede decir exactamente
cuánto menos nocivos son y contienen
nicotina
pero también dijo china Quién es impacto
sobre la salud desarrollo cerebral en
adolescentes que continua hasta el
principio o mediados de los 20 años el
amigo tiene también puede dañarlo a los
adultos afectando a la salud
cardiovascular y posiblemente como
viendo el crecimiento de tumores hay
producto químicos incluido muy mucho
metal esperado como plomo níquel como y
cobre y producto cancero
y compuestos
orgánicos volátiles y los ya sabemos que
puede hacer También daño pulmonar haya
habido casos casos de lesiones pulmonar
cada vez asociadas con el bateo en
cualquier caso la conclusión principal y
que sea aunque los cigarrillos
electrónicos pueden ser mendañinos que
los cigarrillos de trabajo tradicionales
no son inocuos y siempre es mejor dejar
de fumar por completo en lugar de
cambiar a otro producto potencialmente
dañino
estaba hablando precisamente
del daño que puede hacer la nicotina a
los adolescentes durante las personas
jóvenes y que de hecho es una de las
poblaciones que más con más entusiasmo
digamos está empezando a usar este tipo
de dispositivos como El cigarrillo
electrónico preocupa que pueda ser una
puerta de entrada a otros hábitos como a
pasar a fumar tabaco en este caso Cuáles
son los riesgos de que particularmente
esta población vea en el vapeo una
opción o saludable
se ha vuelto cada vez más popular entre
los jóvenes y eso es para la adicción a
la nicotina es un problema Yo la mayoría
de los cigarrillos electrónicos
contienen nicotina y nicotina y
muy muy superior
es una puerta de entrada al tabaco
algunas investigaciones que lleven que
los jóvenes
electrónicos pueden tener más
posibilidades de comenzar a usar
producto de tabaco tradicional como
cigarrillos en el futuro
Hay riesgo para la salud y también hay
un riesgo de normalización del
comportamiento de fumar el aumento del
uso de cigarrillos electrónicos
entre los jóvenes protegía llevar a la
nominación de los acompañamientos de
fumar en general en la sociedad lo que
dificultaría la aplicación de la
prohibiciones de fumar y la prohibición
de estilo de la promoción de estilo de
vida libres de tabaco lo que estamos
asistiendo es a un aumento muy grave del
consumo de cigarrillos electrónicos en
particular lo de unos usos solo en los
jóvenes en los adolescentes pero lo
vemos también en niños de 16 años porque
también esto se puede consumar en una
manera muy
inacondida en la escuela y eso es un
problema muy muy grave
Luciano rubia Gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en directo
Muchas gracias ymar gracias a usted
también por acompañarnos Gracias a ti
María Clara nos vemos mañana nos vemos
mañana y nosotros continuamos con más
noticias internacionales
[Música]